je m'appelle romain gauthier et jean ma
vie professionnelle ça va plutôt bien
pour le reste c'est un peu plus
compliqué qu'avant campagne mon frère
c'est une énigme comme en son temps ou
quand on se comprend pas trop ce qui est
sûr c'est que depuis tout petit je suis
son jouet préféré que votre père
présente tous les symptômes d'une
démence à corps de lewy plaisant tard
j'ai pas de réserve et ta mère se
promène en kyoto supermarché c'est
maintenant que time
c'est une dépression écoutez nous avons
le problème
ça fait des mois qu'ils se posent et qui
veut pas en parler j'ai un service à vos
demandes et qu'on étouffé avec un
oreiller pourrait combler le déficit de
la sécu lamarre foire à ce foutu nora
lichti sinon les vire tu es jolie tu es
encore très très bien pour 95 n'ont
jamais trop parlé en son honneur
on fait quoi dans la vie commence à
peine après la rencontre ici chez lui
tokyo a en fait je donne quelques cours
de barros faire c'est comme du pollen
starter
le rôle du bon fils d'evry doit beaucoup
mieux qu'à moi a toujours cherché à lui
plaire j'espère au moins que cette fois
il a pressé haut depuis six mois
adroitement vouloir c'était d'avoir
bonne conscience et toi tu te maries
quand il est vraiment bien
n'y pense même pas même de mettre la
très forte personnalité
tu sais pas ce que c'est d'avoir un
frère comme le mien
l'amour est plus fort que tout il va
triompher